E aí
[Música]
o Olá muito de vocês provavelmente não
irão conseguir ser antifa
Olá eu sou uma pessoa que gosta desse
universo geek como você pode estar vendo
desenhos animados universo Star Wars
games todo esse contexto que envolve
super-heróis filmes e muito mais mas
também sou uma pessoa que gosta de
esportes só aperta uma boa maratonista
pratica atividade física com muita
frequência seria então eu Henrique para
muito nerd ou atleta amador
e esse é o que nós chamamos de vieses
inconscientes Nós seres humanos é normal
colocar no
o bico de Caxias e a vemos o que
pré-julgamentos o tempo todo estamos
associando pessoas a determinadas
situações coisas
é isso parece muito também com a
tecnologia muita gente acha que
tecnologia está ligado associada conta
hortas ou mesmo processos mas esquece e
não tem uma visão tanto é que a
tecnologia está muito mais ligado à
pessoas o impacto toda nova tecnologia
causa o impacto na sociedade que sejam
político que seja cultural ou mesmo que
seja social EA Justamente que hoje eu
vou trazer para você importância da
tecnologia e esses impactos que ela pode
que ocasiona na sociedade
o principal a principal ativo isso
o que a empresa de qualquer negócio são
as pessoas dessas tecnologias justamente
vão impactar elas que fazem de fato o
mundo caminhar
é um famoso filósofo da comunicação
chamado Marshall macluhan eu conheci
esse cara quando estudei publicidade há
quase 20 anos atrás tem uma frase dele
que eu muito forte "os homens criam as
ferramentas as ferramentas recriam os
homens
Olá tudo isso que está acontecendo essa
essas novas tecnologias chamados
emergentes as dívidas da quarta
revolução industrial ou da indústria 4.0
isso é tudo muito novo então nosso
cérebro demora para processar todas
essas mudanças que estão acontecendo que
nós estamos vivendo aí esse novo mundo
tem um cérebro primitivo vivendo no
mundo moderno deixa eu contar para vocês
só dois por cento da história da
humanidade
o que está acontecendo durante as
revoluções industriais 98 por cento da
história da humanidade ocorreu
a primitiva ainda muito manual tu por
isso temos dificuldade de processar as
mudanças isso demoram muito aqui
Realmente isso fique inteligível para a
sociedade de uma forma geral e
consigamos com isto absorver e lidar com
todas essas situações e essas novas
tecnologias são criaram sabem mas é uma
linha muito Terry o perigo para ir para
o lado do Alto
a fazer coisas que não são benéficas
notícias para a sociedade e eu vou
trazer Justamente a comparação do
universo Star Wars on fãs já falei sobre
isso esse universo Rico e o perigo é um
médico dessas novas tecnologias e o
controle governança que nós temos temos
que ter sobre essas novas tecnologias
Mas essa eu quero pontuar para vocês
aqui uma coisa que é interessante eu
vamo Eu sempre gostei disso praticar
esportes aí também desse universo Bic
para muitos isso não tem uma congruência
ou aquela pessoa esteriótipo de que
gosta de guerra e de uma pessoa que
geralmente avessa esportes
e eu sempre trabalhei com ele que sempre
gostei desse ingredientes da mesma forma
de jogar videogame desse acaba futebol
brincava de vários outros esportes e
Star Wars Claros de como era criança
ainda mas nunca me painel uma proteção
gostava de outros super-heróis outras só
que é e outras coisas mais ligadas a
esse universo sabe que isso Formou eu
fui realmente dá valor conhecer entendeu
o pedido jamais adolescente porque Bruno
que você fala que isso falou olha que
lhe possibilitou trazer Star Wars de
formas com diversas reflexões e Prazer
diversas metáforas para o mundo
contemporâneo que a gente vive e um
deles aqui nós vamos abordar que hoje o
perigo das novas tecnologias de caminhão
para esse lado negro da força vou
explicar para vocês um pouquinho e falou
assim ó
já prestou atenção e trouxe algo mais
idosos no dessa super franquia
Olá pessoal Star Wars é marcado pela
força
a bolsa é um campo metafísico capaz de
dar poder às pessoas quais são os dois
maiores praticantes da força a origem da
New Civic
eu vou explicar melhor ainda marcada
pela com sentimentos os alto vistas
bondade amor e compaixão e
principalmente sabedoria Qual que é o
principal ícone do lado da Luz todo
mundo Conhece nosso Messi e outra e o
simples situação marcado pelo lado negro
da força com sentimentos como raiva
a inveja e principalmente poder essas
novas tecnologias nos trazem
E olha que interessante como que eu
falei que é uma
a essas novas tecnologias que vêm para o
bem mais caminhar pelo lado do mal e
trazem impactos negativos
é um poderoso de andar chamado Anakin
Skywalker Foi maquinável por um sci-fi
Talvez o sítio mais poderoso los sirios
e eu não sou Anakin Skywalker Anakin
está morto eu sou
um spoiler uma das Fadas mais clássicos
e cores que representa esse universo e
sal voces tem tudo a ver com esse
período
Oi bom dia
o medo medo mas é receio e
principalmente muita sabedoria para
lidar nos coisas novas tecnologias é
preciso envolvemos as três espera
o governo instituições privadas e
principalmente a 4 horas
as normas sejam construídas novas leis
nem Geral de proteção a dados em e
constituída está justamente mitigarmos
esses riscos que as novas tecnologias
podem proporcionar E com isso não trazer
uma sociedade mais inclusiva e
principalmente mais justa eu vou trazer
aqui para vocês três tecnologias
fantásticas consideradas as tecnologias
emergentes que estão presentes no nosso
dia-a-dia como elas podem impactar
justamente ser seduzidos algum lugar do
lado negro da força assim como foi o
Poderoso já dá like se tem Anakin
Skywalker
Bom vamos lá primeira foi se repetindo
mais uma vez só não tenho medo não
precisa tirar as crianças da sala achei
que são cenários Apocalípticos
a fazer mais como reflexão hoje desse
nosso bate-papo Então vamos lá começar a
pela tecnologia que hoje ela tem mais
força e existe uma corrida muito grande
pela grande das grandes principalmente
das duas principais ações pelo domínio
assim como existir pelo espaço que a
inteligência artificial eu citei ela
está no nosso dia a dia a gente vai
olhar no nosso assistente Siri e vários
outros Google
o Ou seja faz parte do nosso dia é uma
obliquidade onipresente não tem como
mais ficarmos sem utilizar essas novas
tecnologias a inteligência artificial
vem justamente para possibilitar uma
sociedade mais frente e como eu falei e
ela tem basicamente três estágios vamos
lá o primeiro explicar de uma forma bem
sucinta Brad mas se você tirar uma
entender primeiro estágio é esse não
gostam de ver que as máquinas ainda
estão na fase de aprendizagem ou seja
isso é muito insistente é o primeiro
estádio ainda a gente chama versão 1.0
e aprendendo com nossos segundo estágio
já está logo ali no futuro bem próximo
que o segundo estado onde as máquinas já
começa a conversarem entre si
o Tom decisões próprias baseadas em
dados
E já consegue conversar já se torna
inteligentes e a projeções que em 2030
logo ele ver que há poucos anos as
máquinas se tornaram mais inteligentes
do que nós
os nossos serviços
É lógico que outros ir ao Sushi hoje mas
bits do teatro o tempo todo
E aí
um ok o estádio que vamos atingir e ele
pode ser muito bom negócios para a
sociedade todos os campos todas as
esferas
o Real perigo é o terceiro estado o
terceiro estágio ele não deve acontecer
justamente as grandes empresas vemos
E aí
E ai meu Deus dos indicam que daqui a 50
anos se pegarmos se deixar um
Inteligência Artificial evoluir no
certo. Chegaremos não esquecer que sabe
que os sábios da supremacia não é um
cenário apocalíptico de filme robô
destruindo humanos vai responder assim
o seu bicho de estimação de alguns ao
doce ele ele Poder Supremo sobre nós
humanos e isso é o Real perigo e não
devemos chegar evitarmos almaço esse
terceiro estágio i
e a nossa estou né Se for bonitinho
tirar está com o pai da inteligência e
com isso vamos perder a essência do ser
humano e Isso não pode acontecer temos
que evitar e controle normas e
regulamentos para que a sociedade
justamente seja mais inclusiva mas
Marques mundo muito melhor
Bom vamos lá para segunda tecnologia
emergente internet das coisas que também
está presente no nosso dia e muitas
vezes a gente não percebe você tá dois
exemplos primeiro veículos carros hoje
novos já tem a tecnologia com wi-fi Ou
seja é nestas coisas quando os
dispositivos estão embarcados ou seja
conectados com a internet
e você chegou em casa você está um
exemplo real que já acontece é verdade
não é futurismo Estou trazendo que não é
futurismo acontece
a vida em países em desenvolvimento com
o caso no Brasil você tá chegando em
casa do seu veículo é que tá a internet
a um clique ou acessando assistente
virtual do computador de bordo você vai
poder ligar viu na sua casa própria lá
naquela temperatura ideal em dias mais
frios disso assistentes já ligamos já o
forno já vai pagar o sono para você
colocar aquele Pão de Queijo do Estado
de Minas Gerais onde que ele não pode
faltar mesmo não sei que mais cedo forno
para chegar em casa já ganhar tempo já
esquentar seu pé Pinheiro para preparar
o café e várias outras ações Ligar para
televisão tudo a um comando por quê
a sua geladeira a geladeira irá
conversar com os humanos e tomar
decisões próprias um exemplo autólogo
Faltou um Ovo manteiga o queijo ela irá
me avisar se você programar
em directo ao supermercado ela vai fazer
compras de forma automatizada ou seja
conectado à Internet irá entender os
nossos comandos e justamente essa troca
entre máquina e humanos para muitos Pode
parecer assustador para outros que gosta
de tecnologia Isso é ótimo vai ganhar
tempo vai ser mais assertivo mas e como
toda essa tecnologia que a princípio
muito boa pode ser reduzida para o lado
negro
a todos os dados estarão indo
é isso se não tiver um controle a sair
de segurança será cada vez mais mais um
perigo eminente temos que ter controle
com os nossos lábios
e hoje estamos juntos infelizmente
desprovidos de privacidade como
controlar ter acesso do controle para o
precisar vamos larga a mão de hackers e
eles têm acesso a todo nossa casa
fechadura a câmera eletrônica e com isso
conseguimos manipular ou mesmo como se
tem está sua casa através de um comando
isso a extremamente perigoso temos que
ter o controle justamente desse nossos
dados porque senão a pessoa consegue
acessar sua rede de acesso à internet
naturalmente da Comando de voz para sua
casa ou cidade inteligente estarão
extremamente conectadas semáforo dos
Campos segurança
E aí
Oi tudo bem
é um
a impressora 3D escrever hoje várias
existe Cadê você pode ter uma impressora
3D a preços acessíveis dentro de casa e
as grandes impressoras estão temperament
moldando toda a cadeia produtiva a
manufatura e de uma mudança com nunca
antes aconteceu você consegue construir
prédios inteiros através de impressora
3D aqui no Brasil uma comunidade no
Nordeste de casa foi construída em menos
de sete dias o que se demorava meses
isso é sensacional não comida João poder
preparar tem algumas próprios alimentos
sapatos eles estão criando hambúrguer
o próprio alguns produzir comida
considerado super alimentos isso é
fantástico Isso é muito bom mais ao
mesmo tempo você consegue produzir um
chá ver a um prédio como se tem
inclusive armas armas químicas produtos
químicos e tecidos humanos e quando você
consegue produzir tecido anos
naturalmente consegue morrer órgãos
dentro de casa Simpsons coração fígado
rim e Sacramento perigoso Como irá ficar
o Mercado Livre
e como Isso poderá ser vendido de forma
obscura no mercado
eu abrir o pressão se tornará realidade
e hacks guiados pelo lado negro da força
poderosa que ao Genoma Humano tenia
temos que nos afetar e tem um controle
sobre isso para evitar o situações que
podem realmente prejudicar muita
evolução enquanto da sociedade o recado
de hoje não é para causar medo é apenas
reflexões e a mensagem final é a
seguinte para me fazer uma provocação
queremos um mundo mais justo
o mundo mais inclusivo
nós queremos o mundo de medo de ganância
e principalmente poder das Nações mais
poderosas e controle supremacia sobre os
demais vale a pena refletir que a força
esteja sempre conosco e muito obrigado